Speaker 1: Colin Powell, former secretary of
state, has died of COVID complications. This story
is creating sort of an intersection of historical
revisionism when it comes to Colin Powell and his
role in foreign policy when he was secretary of
state. This is causing anti-vaxxers to come out of
the woodwork and say Powell was vaccinated and he
died, meaning the vaccine doesn't work. Why bother
and get the vaccine? And it is coming at a time
where we are really wondering what is the future
of this pandemic? So let's talk a little bit about
one article on this, and then we're going to look
at some clips. CNN writing Colin Powell, military
leader, first black U.S. secretary of state,
dies after complications from COVID 19 His
family announced this on Facebook. He was
84. General Colin Powell, former U.S. secretary of
state and chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff,
passed away this morning due to complications from
COVID 19, the family wrote on Facebook, noting he
was fully vaccinated. We have lost a remarkable
and loving husband, father and a great American.
Um, George W. Bush said in a statement
today Powell was a great public servant
who was such a favorite of presidents that he
earned the Presidential Medal of Freedom twice.
Highly respected home and abroad. A family man
and a friend. Though Powell never mounted a White
House bid, he was sworn in as Bush's secretary of
state in 2001. He became the highest ranking black
public official to date in the country, standing
forth in the presidential line of succession.
So this is it. I won't lie and say this is not a
controversial figure in some sense. Colin Powell
still haunted by Iraq and his participation
in making that bogus false case with nonsense
intelligence for going into Iraq in 2003, that's
probably the worst of Colin Powell's legacy.
The good is that Colin Powell did not get pulled
in by the Trump cult, and even prior to that,
did not get pulled in by the right wing xenophobia
racism call when it came to President Barack
Obama. So let's look at what was maybe one of
Colin Powell's best moments, saying, Hey, guys,
it's not just about whether Barack Obama is
a Muslim because it's being used as a slur,
but it's also, if he were, then. So
what? This is maybe Powell's best moment.
Speaker 2: I'm also troubled by not what Senator
McCain says, but what members of the party say,
and it is permitted to be said such things
as well. You know that Mr. Obama is a Muslim.
Well, the correct answer is he is not a Muslim.
He's a Christian. He's always been a Christian.
But the really right answer is what if he is? Is
there something wrong with being a Muslim in this
country? The answer is no, that's not America.
Is there something wrong with some seven year
old Muslim-American kid believing that he or
she could be president? Yet I have heard senior
members of my own party drop the suggestion he's a
Muslim and he might be associated with terrorists.
This is not the way we should be doing it.
Speaker 1: So that's maybe Colin Powell is best.
Now, Colin Powell is maybe worst was participating
in making that case for war in Iraq based on
intelligence. It it seems pretty clear
they knew to be faulty. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: My colleagues, every statement
I make today is backed up by sources
solid sources. These are not assertions. What
we're giving you are facts and conclusions based
on solid intelligence. I will cite some examples
and these are from human sources. Orders were
issued to Iraq's security organizations, as well
as to Saddam Hussein's own office to hide all
correspondence with the Organization of Military
Industrialization. This is the organization,
Speaker 1: and the rest, as they say, is history,
and that was a big factor in making the case for
going into Iraq. One of the greatest foreign
policy blunders of recent decades. So a complex
figure. And of course, we wish his family nothing
but the condolences and thoughts that we would
when someone has lost a loved one
but a politically complex guy. Now,
in terms of the vaccination, there are people who
are going to say this and they're going to say,
See why get vaccinated? Colin Powell was fully
vaccinated and he still died from complications
from COVID. Remember, Colin Powell was 84 years
old. Very, very high risk group. As we know,
no vaccine is 100 percent. And we have seen a very
small number proportionally, but we have seen some
so-called breakthrough deaths. What we should be
saying in reaction to this is wow. It is way more
common to die when you're not vaccinated at any
age. I should get vaccinated. You look at public
hospitalization data. We just got some recent
data from the UK, which is why I mention it.
84 percent of hospitalizations in the UK
were unvaccinated. Only half of one percent
of COVID deaths in the UK were fully vaccinated.
And so while this does happen statistically
and it just so happens that Colin Powell is now
one of those in that group, you are overwhelmingly
protected from hospitalization and from death if
you get vaccinated. So the message should be, wow,
it's newsworthy because it is so rare
statistically that fully vaccinated people die.
This really reinforces the importance of the
vaccine. So that is that's the mathematically
accurate take away that we should get from this
particular situation. Send me your thoughts. You
can find me on Twitter at David Pakman. Tomorrow
is the live viewer town hall tomorrow, Tuesday,
October 19th at six PM Eastern, we will be doing
a wide open phone lines town hall. It will stream
live on the new YouTube channel Pacman Live. If
you look for it on Twitch, if you look for it on
the main YouTube channel, you won't see it. It
is only on the new YouTube channel. Pacman Live
six p.m. Eastern tomorrow. I hope that you will
join me. Our program does depend on the support
of our members, viewers, listeners,
radio audience, podcast listeners,
whoever you are. You can sign up at join Packman
dot com. Support the program. Get all the great
member benefits that come with it, including the
Daily Bonus Show. Sign up at join Packman dot com